all right so it's really no secret that
I am a huge Christopher Nolan fan you
know the director of Batman Begins Dark
Knight and inception you know the little
movies and if you did not already know I
am a fan of Zack Snyder's director of
Donna the dead 300 and Watchmen so if
you take those two and David s Goyer the
co-writer of Batman Begins what do you
get well apparently the next Superman
movie titled Superman the Man of Steel
now this movies kind of had a pretty
funny road after Superman Returns which
I really didn't have too much of a
problem with except for the fact that it
took place five years after - and
Brandon Routh was like 26 when they
filmed it which would make him 21 in
Superman - but Jeremy Einstein's theory
of relativity alright fine Einstein's
theory of relativity I got you but even
then he looks 22 so I mean seriously but
even then it was still five years for
the people on earth and in that five
years they went from 80s haircuts and
little shitty four by three tube TVs to
plasma screens and Windows Vista that is
quite the technological boom the studio
decided they wanted to reboot which is
fine with me I mean I want to see what
they can do with Superman like a fresh
start with Superman so I guess after the
Dark Knight David s Goyer and
Christopher Nolan they were just
brainstorming where they'd go with
Batman 3 and they just hit some sort of
writer's block and David s Goyer was
like oh by the way Chris I was
brainstorming Superman for some unknown
reason this is what I would do with the
movie I guess Nolan was like that is
exactly what you should do with the
movie that is awesome so I guess Nolan
pitched it to the studio and the studio
loved it because I mean he's Christopher
Nolan he's brought longer brothers a lot
of money so they made him the executive
producer of project Superman CPR which
is really funny that David s Goyer wrote
it because four years ago David s Goyer
said that he didn't think that he'd be
good writing a Superman script yeah oops
on that which is fine because in 2004
Obama said that he wouldn't be ready to
be president in 2008 and four years
later yeah I'm not gonna lie that
comparison really doesn't inspire much
confidence in me either
so they have their script and a producer
they need a director and bam they get
Zack Snyder the director of watchmen and
300 and with the main villain said to be
General Zod one of the more iconic
Superman villains I'm thinking we're in
business but if I find out that Superman
throws a cellophane s off his chest
I am boycotting that now one thing
that they've all address and I
personally agree with is that
translating Superman to the big screens
really hard because other than the
Kryptonite thing the guy is just
indestructible so that makes it really
hard to relate to him or even give a
about
but they swear they found a way to make
a modern and relatable I just really
hope that doesn't mean butchering the
lore too much but it apparently has the
stamp of approval from the guy who's
like hey move over power right here's
how you make a good Batman movie and
here you go BAM that's how you make a
good sequel on here you go is just
doodle the script for this movie on a
bubble young rapper while I was taking a
last Tuesday I mean so I mean who
knows that might be cool so what do you
guys think do you think we're gonna get
the Superman movie that we've been
waiting for for about three decades now
and who do you think should play
Superman or Zod comment below and get
that going and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more that's at the time Papapa that's my
Superman theme see me